shulie show us uh eric's apartment give
us a tour of some of the things you
wanted to show us
all right eric roll over and and get
your phone
oh you [ __ ] i don't want to fall off
see this is my stash of candy in the
band
now see that's right next to his bed so
if he gets hungry in the middle of the
night
he doesn't have to get up this is my
office where work
would work what do you mean work you
don't have a job when i do my cameos
this is my bathroom
this is my bidet toilet look he has a
bidet
toilet howard that he shoots warm water
up his ass he doesn't want to leave that
thing
i want to see you shoot water up your
ass go ahead i have a heated toilet seat
all right you hear it
yeah that's the water going in your
[ __ ] oh my god what's that
belly fat he's showing us his belly and
his ass looks like the moon
well there you go there's eric on his
toilet desert i think you want to go to
your fridge
okay hold on let me make sure i don't
drop the phone in the toilet
i haven't happened to do it these are
everyday concerns for him by the way
okay so i'll open my freezer first
all right so i have some ice cream first
thing i see is m m's ben
jerry's i mean eric what the hell are
you
eating oh my god
let me see the fridge let me see what
else is going in there i have whipped
cream
and avial tequila i counted three things
of whipped cream
in his fridge i don't know who needs
that much whipped cream because i put
the whipped cream
in my espresso he puts it in everything
sure
and show the pantry show howard your
pantry okay okay
there's two boxes of entertainment at
the top now underneath that you count
one two three four five those are all
double packs of oreos what is that
nutter butter you got
peanut butter cookies peanut butter
oreos
i got potato chips when i wanna have a
cocktail on the side
you know what he means with his cocktail
he has uh chips of course
oh he's got clorox in the pantry okay
keep it away don't worry virus
my gatorades eric where's your pill box
my toe box i didn't need to do that this
morning
oh right here oh my god
look at that that's a pill box for an
entire wing
of a hospital in the morning i take
about 15 pills a day
that's just in the morning eric yes
yeah this is the morning and this is for
the afternoon
oh my god that is a tremendous amount of
medication
right and then you have evening pills
early evening
early evening
you have morning afternoon early evening
and nighttime pills
it is a giant tackle box filled with
pills
i mean i have a playstation
a big tv oh how is it three tvs
by the way two right next to each other
on the wall he has two so he can watch
two different shows at the same time
well what i've learned is because of
this business that he has on cameo where
people pay him to make messages
he's got a strangely large amount of
money
he has an apartment that's the size
maybe of a closet
and yet it is 75 to 80 food and
appliances i would say you know
and and whatever isn't food and
appliances it's a bed
you